okay so there's a trailer to the Black
Widow movie which at this point I don't
even know what's Disney plus or
theatrically released anymore it's all
just crazy but I guess this is a
theatrically released Black Widow movies
and we finally have a Black Widow movie
which means only one thing I'm probably
gonna gripe in this video a little more
than I should about why this movie
didn't come out a few years ago you know
when people were really asking for it
before she was boilers for Avengers
endgame dead regardless we have a
trailer for the black widow movie and it
looks about as cool as I figured it
would look after Captain America Winter
Soldier came out there I go it already
started so I guess this takes place
after Captain America Civil War but
before Avengers infinity war between the
wars there is the widow and it looks
like a thriller spy espionage movie in
which to [ __ ] she has a sister it's good
to see you too sis I didn't know and
since I always got the feeling Clint
Barton was pretty much the most
important person in her life it could be
one of two things one she's not that
close to her sister it happened to her
sister's not living through this sorry
sis gonna die today we get a glimpse a
taskmaster which is paintball mask I
don't know about that I also imagine
this is taskmaster pre taskmaster but I
know about taskmasters he pretty much
has perfect muscle memory he's pretty
much like that girl in Heroes season -
you remember heroes season - no bless
you but in heroes season 2 there was
that girl that could see something and
she was just she would have the muscle
memory now for it pretty much what I
know about taskmaster he learns other
hero's abilities pretty sweet you can do
some really cool stuff with it and I
imagine by the end of this movie he'll
have the skull mask and the cape and
he'll look more like taskmaster this is
like crossbones before he was crossbones
and he was just frank grillo and he was
he was still rad it's Frank Grillo come
on so as you get your sleek action spy
thriller with Black Widow also you get
some pretty ridiculous [ __ ] I mean that
is ridiculous probably gonna be pretty
sweet to watch I was thinking about this
about Marvel it that's not even the most
ridiculous thing I can think of I'm not
even thinking about ant-man who can grow
to the size of a building or shrink down
to the quantum level I'm not even
talking about that it was also that
really angry member berri you remember
I'm member he snapped his finger and he
wiped out half of all life in the
universe that comparison that's not too
nuts that's actually a pretty sweet zone
Marvel's in the suspension of disbelief
it's just they've done
much think I'm pretty much do anything
with great power comes great
responsibility so be responsible don't
go too crazy it can't have God just
appear and start dick lifting everybody
I mean I'd be like that's a little crazy
and David Harbor is red guardian only
know about him because admittedly I have
his hero clique I was into that game for
a bit then I got it was like oh wow it's
like a Russian Captain America it's
pretty much what he is and I love it
when comic books bring in the Cold War
escalation did step that was just a very
real thing still is like escalation
among countries still real so if we act
Captain America the Russians would
definitely have an equivalent to Captain
America and he is yeah that is as David
Harbor as I've seen and that speech is
in Captain America the First Avenger you
remember Gould becomes good eight it
becomes buzz in David hava becomes much
more debatable and that is much more
David Harvard it's like David Harbor
stepped in the TGR I'm mutagen news
canister and became some super David
Harbor it's about time for a black widow
movie I'm just saying
ever since Captain America Winter
Soldier a lot of fans myself included
were like all good she's awesome let's
let's bring that solo movie on it's like
they were just like we need a movie with
a strong female character I just can't
think of what we have it's not coming to
my mind only we had one hey that's a
good idea there's weird this didn't
happen earlier Black Widow earned her
spot years ago I'm glad she's finally
getting the solo treatment she deserves
something would've been better to have
this released while in the MCU she was
still you know spoilers for avengers
endgame alive oh no looks pretty fun
race to the Black Widow trailer have you
seen it why did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]
you